hapsatou sy vous en doutez les
chroniqueurs et les téléspectateurs ont
plein de questions pour vous en tout cas
merci d'être avec nous on se rappelle
vous avez voit là ou quittez salut les
terriens suite à votre altercation avec
eric zemmour donc hapsatou après vous
avez un réagi sur installant vous avez
fait part de votre détermination ne pas
vous laisser faire suite à cette
altercation regarder et il ya plein de
questions c'est parti c'est les 5
minutes de vérité c'est parti nous
sommes presque une semaine après
l'enregistrement des terriens du
dimanche où j'ai eu effectivement une
scène extrêmement violente face à eric
zemmour
je ne peux pas accepter que les
règlements soient partie du plateau en
ricanant en me regardant impunément
comme si rien ne s'était passé alors
qu'ils venaient de m'insulter comme
jamais j'ai été insulté je vais diffuser
les images vous allez les voir tout de
suite et après il y aura plus de
discussion je prends un risque de perdre
mon boulot
et comme tout le monde j'ai besoin de
bosser g20 payer mes charges mais je le
fais je le fais parce qu'il est hors de
question de monsieur zemmour continue et
on a quelque chose à vous annoncer la
capsat où dans un instant juste poser
vos questions à chaque type mpeg ça tous
ont des premières questions de valérie
benaïm oui absolument ça juste pourquoi
est-ce que vous continuez à entretenir
la polémique avec thierry ardisson
parce que lorsque vous êtes vous il ya
eu une première réponse de sa part vous
avez répondu il a surenchéri vous avez à
nouveau répondu pourquoi un moment vous
dis pas stop je réponds plus que l'on
passe à autre chose
c'est un très bon conseil que vous ne me
donnez là sauf que quand on le vit c'est
assez difficile évidemment moi je pense
qu'à un moment je ne crois pas au
principe de dire qu'il faut répondre à
la bêtise par le silence la bêtise ça ce
combat parce que la bêtise a provoqué
des trucs était pas terrible au fur et à
mesure et les années passées donc moi
j'ai été agressée non combas eric
zemmour ça n'a jamais été thierry
ardisson mais thierry ardisson a décidé
de m'affronter publiquement pour une
raison que je n'arrive pas à expliquer
donc il relance comme ça la polémique en
permanence moi j'ai décidé de simplement
pas me laisser faire parce qu'à la base
c'est moi qui a été insulté
après je considère que tout le monde est
saoulé par cette polémique moi la
première
je me balade dans la rue je me fais
appeler par un prénom qui m'a été
assignée par eric
et moore pas le prénom que m'ont donné
mes parents chauveau au coeur en les
gens m'appellent corinne dans la rue ils
pensent que c'est sympathique et tout
mais il y en a qui est pour lesquels
c'est moins sympathique c'est pas le
prénom m'ont donné mes parents mes
parents m'ont appelé absatou donc j'ai
pas envie d'entretenir cette polémique
parce que c'est pour moi c'est un bad
buzz mais c'est un combat que je pouvais
pas en fait c'est un affrontement au
départ avec eric zemmour ce que je
pouvais pas laisser comme ça mais pas ça
n'a jamais été contre eux tirés indécise
au belmont ibos alors maintenant le
clash et consommer ce que vous regrettez
pas sincèrement entre cadieux devoir
quitter les terriens du dimanche
absolument pas vous ne regrettez pas du
tout je ne regrette absolument pas je
considère que travailler pour une chaîne
sait aussi être respectées
voilà j'ai pas été respectées je parle
pas par la chaîne je parle vraiment pas
rock si on parle d'équipés et par la
production
j'ai un peu de respect à un peu de
dignité pour moi même voilà j'ai pas
envie d'accepter ça s'il ya des gens
qu'il accepte c'est leur problème
moi j'ai pas envie du tout ça donc donc
jeté difficile il ya un truc qui s'est
brisée il ya un truc qui s'est rompu et
dans une relation contient un truc
simple ça sert à rien de rester de de
faire l'hypocrite je pense qu'à un
moment faut faut aller j'espère autre
chose et assumer ses choix alors vous
dites que n'ait pas été soutenus
justement il ya un tweet il arriver
puisqu'ils pouvaient voter vous posez
vos questions à bsat ou s'il vous plaît
tweet merci depuis que vous avez quitté
les terriens du dimanche avez vous pu
garder des contacts avec des personnes
de l'équipe donc les chroniqueurs c'est
franck de abreu qui nous qui vous
demande je n'ai plus jamais eu personne
au téléphone fixe si ce n'est ses
raquettes garrido et j'ai changé j'ai
échangé plusieurs fois qu' effectivement
peiné que j'ai quittée puis je suis non
le reste six personnes non en fait il ya
eu aussi des mensonges là je sais que
stéphane simon est venu sur votre peau
est producteur du mal à thierry ardisson
ils ont dit que je répondais pas à leurs
appels je n'ai jamais jamais été appelé
par tirer ardisson d'accord mais depuis
l'incident avec eric zemmour pas même un
sms donc je considère qu effectivement
quand on a travaillé plus d'un an pour
une personne et qu'il ya un conflit on
peut aussi se parler et là j'étais pas
fautive
contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire donc
voilà on ne sait jamais parlé on sait
avec stéphane simon on a un petit peu
échangé mais rien de rien de plus avec
le produit une autre question sur
twitter s'il vous plaît alors est il
normal de demander à sa maquilleuse de
filmer les missions en cachette alors
c'est ce qui vous a été reprochée oui il
m'a dit vous aviez demandé à votre
maquilleuse de filmer les coulisses de
l'émission est de
filmé l'émission avec c'est ce qu'a dit
tir ardisson avec son portable donc le
retour de l'émission on en coulisses
je suis ravie comme pose cette question
parce que je n'y ai pas du tout répondu
pour le moment
comment imaginez vous qu'avec un
téléphone portable on puisse enregistrer
quatre heures d'émission dont les
extraits non mais même des extraits
c'est à dire que j'aurais prémédité
l'action c'est à dire que à jeudi ont
péri mais que vous avez vous aimé du
tout dans quelques séries dit quelque
chose qui est absolument intenable nos
maquille nos coiffures tous les plateaux
télé souvent prennent non retour en
photos
donc ils ont leurs téléphones portables
ils se baladent sur le plateau thierry
le serbe fait des selles fille ensemble
il fait des selles fille avec ma
maquilleuse
il voudrait que j'ai dit à ma
maquilleuse presse devant l'écran et
surtout s'il ya un bain ou c'est faux
c'est un film le là vraiment je vais
aller au bout du truc parce que c'est
surréaliste de dire ça ont filmé une
séquence devant un écran pendant quatre
heures d'émission où on ne sait pas ce
qui va se passer si j'avais demandé à ma
maquilleuse de filmer depuis le début de
l'émission
j'aurais pas rater les deux minutes qui
précèdent ce que j'ai ce qu'on a
effectivement nos régions qui sont des
mets pire que ce qu'il a pu me dire
j'aurais film et dès le début de l'
échange
j'aurais eu toute la longueur de
l'échangé j'aurais pu tout difficile à
tout juste il ya des gens aussi qui ont
dit que vous filmer les coulisses de
l'émission oui ce n'est pas du tout on
fait du cinéma d'estoril et les gens qui
me suivent wall et story que je diffuse
sur les réseaux sociaux rien contre eux
tu es en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que 1
ça c'est un mensonge qui est absolument
formel 2g aucun intérêt à le faire trois
s'émeut me prêter un pouvoir absolu que
de mettre des mots dans la bouche d'eric
zemmour pour avoir un buzz je sais
qu'ils ont utilisé la couverture de
management que j'avais fait où il y
avait écrit un titre
l'homme parle en bien ou en mal si les
gens cliquent écoute l'interview
ils entendront que je donne des conseils
à des entrepreneurs qui sont plutôt
positifs et que je n'ai pas du tout bad
buzz mais dans cette interview y avait
cinq ou six personnes qui étaient
interviewés et peut-être d'autre part
les bad buzz mais ça n'a jamais été mon
cas donc sur cette préméditation faut
qu'il arrête ça se faire des films et
d'imaginer que j'ai demandé sa
maquilleuse c'est conforme à lui seul
film we alors justement al'inverse est
ce que t as tu as l'impression que tu es
tombé dans un piège
soit pour faire la promotion du buzz
d'eric zemmour du livre pardon d'eric
zemmour soit pour peut-être arrêter
votre contrat avec la production alors
clairement eric zemmour il n'a pas
besoin de moi pour vendre un livre il
vend ses
de toute façon il a une armée derrière
lui qui le soutiennent pas ce que vous
faites tomber dans un sulfate je suis
pas tombé dans un piège mais évidemment
j'ai eu il ya eu il ya eu comme des ja
du passif dans cette émission mais quand
vous êtes dans ma chair dans dans ce que
je suis c'est à dire qu'on le veuille ou
non une femme noire et bien quand il ya
des débats sur des sujets qui touchent à
l'histoire de la communauté noire ou
autre comment voulez vous que je ne
réagissent pas donc il ya eu des
antécédents il ya eu des débats
extrêmement houleux déjà avec thierry
ardisson sur ce sujet là et évidemment
il sexy m'a pris dans cette émission
c'est aussi parce que j'avais un fort
caractère que je réponds que j'argumente
on m'a dit que j'avais fait la pleureuse
j'ai jamais fait la pleureuse dans
l'émission de tirer au contraire j'ai
été au combat sur chaque débat sur sept
chaque sujet en revanche c'est sûr que
le débat il s'arrête à l'insulter oui au
moment où l'on commencé à m'insulter je
suis plus dans le débat faut pas me
demander de débattre je suis insulté
donc j'ai effectivement dit pendant
l'émission je n'ai aucune question à
poser à ce monsieur qui vient de passer
cinq minutes à main vous pourrir
vraiment moi moi d'abord je l'avais
questions questions à zemmour il a été
idiot totalement la question que je veux
te poser c'est est arrivé ici parce que
tu t'es battu qu'à une force de
caractère tu serais pas ici tout ce que
tu as traversé dans ta vie tu serais pas
ici
cantine et il déconne à t'appeler sur
pattes qui préparera une patte appelé
mireille temps appeler comme ça parce
que c'est cesser les cerises il faut pas
oublier de dire ma question il t'a dit
les gens de l'équipe et on part appelé
ça c'est une chose mais est ce que eric
zemmour il tape tape à de nouvelles avec
lui non plus pas d' excuses par appeler
ni rien écoutez je dis juste encore une
fois un jeu ne tient pas ce qu'eric
zemmour on appelle ça c'est eric zemmour
c'est ce fameux même nom donc j'attends
même même pour s'excuser je pense pas
qu'ils s'excusent de toute façon je dis
juste une chose un peu les yeux de tous
et que je trouve que les émissions comme
celle de thierry ardisson protège les
types comme eric zemmour pourquoi parce
qu'elles ne sont pas en direct
donc il sait qu'il peut vous insultez
pendant 20 minutes allaient à l'encontre
de la loi c'est ce qu'a dit thierry
ardisson moi j'ai une question à poser
attirèrent 10 ans thierry ardisson a dit
à tout le monde
elle va quoi les propos d'eric zemmour
aller à l'encontre de la loi
pourquoi ne pas avoir réagi ça veut dire
qu'en gros il sait que le type mans sud
le pays n'était l'ignorer
chip affaire l'avocat de tyr a disons
quand vous êtes en émission parfois vous
laissez passer des choses voilà oui
après vous ai regretté derrière mais
c'est vrai que nous avons regretté
derrière vous assassinez pas en public
votre chroniqueuse moi j'aurais apprécié
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
thierry ardisson et son travail par le
passé c'est qui me passent juste un coup
dessus dans dix ans effectivement ce que
tu as vécu sur le plateau le n'est pas
acceptable n'est pas admissible mais la
défense gratter un peu mais il ne
regrette rien du tout puisqu'il a
continué à entretenir la polémique loi
là je le regrette
moi je regrette ça parce que je pensais
qu'il aurait un peu plus de classe et
d'élégance et qu'il aurait su ramener le
débat entre près par rapport à ce que
j'ai vécu avec zemmour et pas par
rapport à lui parce que encore une fois
ce n'était pas mon ennemi
j'ai vu tout ce qui s'est passé vu ce
que vous reprochez là encore attiré
ardisson est ce que vous regrettez
d'avoir travaillé avec lui non je
regrette pas d'avoir travaillé avec lui
parce que pour moi thierry ardisson il
incarnait le génie de la télévision il
avait des idées ils avaient des concepts
et c'est ce que je regrette c'est
d'avoir travaillé avec lui maintenant
parce que pour moi il est plus le génie
qu'il a été par le passé de dur alors on
a une question encore sur twitter e
si vous devez choisir bas mais en ce
moment je pense que ça va être marrant
qu'elle veut et qu'elle m'aime vraiment
pas du tout mais voilà dans façon y'a
pas choisir c'est vrai que voilà là
aujourd'hui
vous êtes sur ces 8 ou ont tenu à être
sûr c'est vite et bien sûr la question
que tout le monde se pose c'est l'avenir
d'absa tout si sur ces 8 eh bien on peut
vous le dire vu ce qu'on s'est mis
d'accord tous les deux hier absatou vous
allez rejoindre l'équipe de balances ton
post donc les missions qu'on fait le
vendredi soir donc en deuxième partie de
soirée et absatou nous rejoint je suis
très très heureux de la firme saison est
ce que tu sais que je t'ai toujours
voilà je n'étais toujours suivi depuis
des années même quand tu faisais le
grand huit avec laurence ferrari et ça
fait longtemps que j'avais envie de
travailler avec toi
et là ça y est ça se concrétise donc je
suis très heureux même moi aussi je suis
très heureuse et ont beaucoup de gens
disent en permanence qu'on s'est clashé
c'est le monde daté ça arrive on se dit
on se bagarre on se défendre voilà on
s'est toujours dit les choux on s'est
toujours were réconcilier et souvent
avec des gros comme toi comme tu vas te
faire un gros bisou je suis très heureux
qu il fasse partie de l'équipe vraiment
vraiment excellent voilà est-ce que vos
justes pedrag chose que si vous êtes
contents super je suis s'appelait
pouliches et c'est vous le dire je suis
content tu vas à balances ton pass c'est
une émission que moi je regardais que
j'adore mais c'est très dur c'est d'y
renoncer à une chose c'est que je n'ai
pas peur des débats c'est comme ça qu'en
région
non mais avec eric zemmour j'ai débattu
sauf que c'est une émission qui monte et
ça a été la sortie
simplement je n'ai pas peur des débats
je suis là pour débattre je suis pour la
liberté d'expression contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu dire mais je suis contre
olemps à main merci